Hello again!
The last time I was here on Crash Course
we spent a year working our way through the
wonders of physics.
I’m excited to be back again to talk about
something even dearer to my heart: engineering.
Why am I excited?
Because I’m an engineer!
But what exactly is engineering?
A lot of things, actually.
For now, we’ll just say that the history of
engineering encompasses
the creation of everything from the physical
objects around you to the processes allowing
you to watch this video right now.
That’s like, really broad, I know.
Don’t worry – we’ll talk about what
that means in a little more detail in our
first episode.
There are actually multiple fields of
engineering and we’re going to spend some
time with each of them.
We’ll explain the difference between and
the history of civil, mechanical, electrical,
and chemical engineering.
And those four disciplines still don’t account
for all of engineering.
But over the next year we’re going to try
to get to the heart of what all of that means.
We’ll look at how engineers see problems
in the world and then try to solve them.
That problem-solving mindset has helped
engineers create everything from spaceships to
coffee cups, wireless earbuds to dog whistles,
artificial hearts to roads and bridges.
Before we do that, though, allow me to reintroduce
myself.
I’m Dr. Shini Somara, and I started my science
career studying maths and physics at college.
I then went on to study Mechanical engineering.
And out of everything I learned during my first degree,
what fascinated me the most was fluid dynamics,
and understanding how gases and liquids flow.
So I researched this topic at depth for 4.5
years, earning myself a Doctorate of Engineering
in the process.
Since then I’ve worked as a science
communicator for the BBC, Al Jazeera
and even right here on Crash Course.
I’m excited to be back to talk about something
that has meant the world to me.
Over the next 46 episodes, we’re gonna get
a feel for how engineering and engineers have
shaped our world.
I hope you’ll join me – and our friends
at PBS Digital Studios – on this journey
with Crash Course: Engineering.